I want to start by saying congrats on
the show I thought it was fantastic and
I'm gonna ask this question for all the
people that are gonna watch it and
finish episode eight like I just did
when can I see season two yeah I'm
asking the same question we would love
to know that I think the plan is to make
it by the end of this year so hopefully
soon but I don't know when Netflix will
choose to give it to the world but
definitely coming up
yes sooner than later please alright we
agree
I'm very curious what is it like going
in to meet Ryan for the first time like
because obviously this idea is there and
you you you're hearing that maybe this
is gonna come up but what is it like the
night before you know you're gonna go in
you know you're gonna meet on the
project are you like in your head a
little bit more are you overthinking are
you thinking about the clothes like what
is it like everything you know he's so
particular about every element of his
shows so you know he's gonna be as
particular about that first experience I
think totally I think I probably over
thought it more than he ever did but
then I don't know is then just really
nice he's really kind and supportive and
encouraging and I think I always
chuckles down from the top 100% I had a
sort of a strange experience because he
came to see musical I was doing and I
met him backstage at that which was sort
of a very decompressed place to meet him
since I had just sort of done a show and
I was all my sort of my guard was down
so it was a little less intense than
like meeting him at sort of a general or
something like that and then shortly
thereafter he asked me to have a meal
and sort of pitch me this idea that he
had based on having seen that show and I
was like okay that sounds wonderful but
you never know what those things are
gonna turn out to be and then it was the
show and he had every sort of bit of the
detail and vision completely fleshed out
in his mind and each and every component
came fully to fruition which was my
first impression of him and sort of
solidified in my mind when we think we
already knew which is just his ability
to really follow through and that's sort
of why he's able to be so prolific is
that all of these brilliant ideas and
things that he comes up with he can
really make happen at such a high
quality level on every every level I'm
curious so you telling you about the arc
how much do you guys know about the arc
of the whole season before
filming began how much do you have a
vague idea and how much is it like
script my script I was an executive
producer so I got a bit of the of the
sort of overarching they were individual
twists and there's a lot of twists and
turns and love triangles and betrayals
and such that he wanted us to experience
the reading each script so there wasn't
those individual plot points were left
very much up in the air sorry for me but
I knew sort of generally where Payton
was going to end up and what the sort of
vision long-term was for the show and
for each character but but I definitely
each time I was reading the script was
looking to find out what was happening
yeah I mean he described the argue I
think as every new script came in you
thought you knew more than you actually
did and then the huge plot twists and
turns themselves is really one of the
things that I really love about Ryan is
his commitment to inclusion and
diversity both in front of and behind
the camera can you both talk about what
that means to you and just being part of
a show that pushes things like that
100% I think that what makes Ryan so
brilliant as far as inclusion and
diversity is concerned is that it always
feels like a piece of the tapestry of
the piece and never sort of the purpose
of it altogether I think it always feels
very natural to the story that he's
being told and then obviously behind the
camera in this particular situation
anytime we had a director that was not
one of the three writers and creators of
the show we had a brilliant female
director at Helen Hunt and Janet mock
and Gwyneth order Payton and I just
think he wherever as possible really
walks the walk as far as keeping
opportunities as open as possible and
trying to include as many different
perspectives as possible because that's
what makes the best stuff I think yeah
and you see how his projects develop as
well with the kind of changing times and
the opening up of minds as well it's
never a kind of forced education with
his shows it's never a kind of you see
it's always the encouragement of
conversation and just the increasing
presence of everything and awareness
which is always I think the most
positive way to go in it there are a lot
of cool moments during the eight
episodes is there one that you were like
extremely excited to film or extremely
nervous
film something that really got in your
head you know I think just generally the
first scene I had to do with Jessica
Lange was at the end of the pilot that's
the first thing that we shot together
and I'm just such a I mean like most of
the planet a giant fan of hers and an
admirer of her work and was so eager to
sort of see how she works on set and was
worried that I'd be too busy being
fascinated by that to be doing my job so
I was very scared for that day and for
that reason but then it was you know
flying colors it was she was just
incredible and open and wanted to play
and made me excited for you know how God
willing if I'm around and keep working
and just to get to that point in my
career and still be that excited and
open and try new things it it was just
it was really thrilling I think it was
the Ryan Murphy aspect of it that was
most daunting for me I remember the
first day doing scenes with David and
just trying to marry that kind of
elevated way that Ryan the element
elevated element that Ryan's shows have
the very kind of theatric theatricality
meets reality I'm trying to gauge both
of those engage what he's thinking at
the same time and do justice to love
that it was someone don't in stressful
um my this is a completely different
kind of question what TV show would you
love to guest star on have you watched
ed to me no then you won it's so great
so maybe that I love that dog company
another Netflix show I'd love to do a
voice on big mouth I really love girls
very much
and Courtney curls a good friend and I
would love to even just bobby anyone
I'll pop in and do it car sounds I would
love to see that here I have to say one
of my favorite shows on television and
you would be perfect because of the way
it mixes in songs only I cannot say
enough good things for people watching
big mouth phenomenal agree on that note
you guys have a fantastic day and
seriously congrats on the show thank you
so good